america is the world's greatest
superpower at least it has been for
quite some time but has there been a
transition a coup
has china upstaged the united states as
the world's most influential country if
not now
could it happen soon the pandemic taught
us anything can happen
and then we should be prepared for that
possibility after all the virus didn't
send our nation into a downward spiral
while china came out on top look however
the coronavirus originated its effects
are clear
we are economically set back they are up
we turn in on ourselves we fight we
divide ourselves
they excel we pull back on energy and
they march forward
the effects kind of make you raise your
eyebrows at the latest news out of china
while the rest of the world presses to
find out whether or not coveted came
from the wuhan
institute of virology china says the lab
not only deserves award for quote
outstanding science and technology
but also should receive an even higher
honor a top spokesman for the chinese
foreign ministry says quote the genome
sequence
of coven 19 was first identified by a
chinese scientist
but that does not mean the wuhan is the
source of the coronavirus
the team in wuhan should be awarded the
nobel prize in medicine for their
research on covet 19
instead of being criticized it's a
little odd
a little bit of an attaboy everything
worked out beautifully
so the point is whether the leak was an
accident or purpose for
purposeful it crumbled america while
placing china in a perfect position to
gain power
so was all this part of their master
plan i don't have the answer to that i
don't know but i will say
it does serve their master plan china
has made no secret of their desire to
replace the united states as
the world's prominent superpower xi
jinping slightly referenced this
this global shift in power during a
conference back in april he said quote
global governance should reflect the
evolving political and economic
landscape
in the world one or a few countries
shouldn't impose their rules on others
and the world shouldn't be led by the
unilateralism
of a few countries so what does that
mean here now to react
louisiana center john kennedy senator so
great to see you on the program tonight
there's been some talk for quite some
time
about china's 100-year plan there's no
hiding it they want to replace the
united states as the world superpower
did we just see them take major strides
major gains in that direction
in my opinion will know
sometimes uh falling
feels like flying for a little while
and china may believe and even boast
that it's a net winner as a result of
the coronavirus
but i think it's a loser i think it's
certainly a loser in the
the worldwide court of public opinion
the chinese people are good people but
the communist party of china lies they
lie like they breathe
they lied about the virus we're now
gathering evidence that the virus not
only originated in china but it might
have originated
from the wuhan lab number two i know
china says it's doing
well economically but once again the
communist party leadership lies
like it's breeze lies like it breathes
we've never been
been able to trust their numbers right
and number three
china was very proud of its covet
vaccine
the fact is it's a very inferior vaccine
china has distributed the vaccine to
about 90 countries
sometimes china extracted concessions
from those countries for example i'll
give you our vaccine
if you support our position on taiwan
but there was an interesting article
that came out today
a lot of the countries that have used
the chinese vaccine are having major
outbreaks of the coronavirus well the
vaccine center is not the only thing
that china is proud of they're proud of
the role that the wuhan institute of
virology played in this entire crisis
they are ready to give the wuhan
institute
of virology an award so as you lay out
all of the manner of sin that china the
chinese communist party committed over
the past year
how do you hold them accountable how
does the united states of america hold
them accountable
here's what we need to do president
biden needs to enlist
the support of other democracies
throughout the world
canada the uk australia
new zealand the eu
south korea japan india
and we need to go to china and demand
not ask but demand full
disclosure we also need to
the president president biden needs to
have a a a prayer session with dr
tedros who work who runs the world
health organization
and uh president biden needs to tell dr
tedros that look
we put up 900 million dollars the
american taxpayer to run your agency
if you don't stand up to china you
better look elsewhere
for that 900 million and if that offends
you i'll help you pack
well i would love to see some of that
accountability china has made no secret
of their 100-year plan they've made no
secret of their desire to replace the
united states as the world's
preeminent superpower let's hope that
the events of the last year
aren't america falling but are actually
flying i saw a crazy heart senator i
know jeff bridges song
sometimes following feels like flying
let's hope we're the ones flying
and they're the ones falling in this
global struggle for power
john kennedy senator john kennedy thank
you so much for your time tonight thank
you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else